[MUSIC PLAYING]
APARNA SINHA: Hi.
I'm Aparna Sinha.
Welcome to day two
of Google Cloud Next.
I'll be co-hosting today
alongside Urs Holzle.
And we've got a really great
lineup of new technology
and demos from Google Cloud.
But before we get
started, I want
to thank you all for taking
time out of your busy week
to be here with us.
Yesterday was an incredible
first day at Next.
Thomas and Sundar made
some amazing announcements.
This week, we're releasing over
100 new products, services,
and programs for you.
We're kicking off day two
now with this keynote,
A Cloud Built for Developers.
After this, we'll jump right
into a live developer Q&A
where you can ask us anything.
And then tomorrow
is Community Day.
And that'll be totally
dedicated to you
for learning,
discussions, networking,
and all kinds of fun.
All right, let's
get things started
by welcoming Urs. Hi, Urs.
URS HOLZLE: Hi, Aparna.
Hi, everyone.
I hope you are as excited as
I am to get started today.
And since this is a
developer keynote,
we'll kick it off
with our first demo
right away from Google Research
and our DeepMind colleagues,
who have been working on some
amazing voice technology.
SPEAKER: Welcome to Next '21.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
URS HOLZLE: Now, before
you get too impressed
by my language skills, I did
not actually speak these words.
What you just heard is a
custom text-to-speech model
that has trained on
my voice and that
can generate synthetic speech
in different languages.
And our teams have
already started
using this technology
to improve our voice
experience for all users.
APARNA SINHA: That's right.
Google's Project Euphonia is
already using custom voice
to help people with
atypical speech
to communicate and
be better understood.
Technology like this creates
a more inclusive world.
To find out more
about this, check out
the Project Euphonia website.
Custom voice is available today
for select Cloud customers.
We're very mindful of
the potential misuses
of this technology, and
we're taking great care
to prevent them by reviewing
each use case uniquely.
URS HOLZLE: Now,
look around you.
Every day, you see
innovation that's
brought to you by
developers like yourself
with persistence and skill.
And Google has a long tradition
of supporting developers
in open source and elsewhere.
For years, you've been
using technologies
like Kubernetes, Firebase,
TensorFlow, Go, Angular,
gRPC, and many others.
And when we built Google Cloud,
we built it for developers.
And we were inspired by all the
things you've created with it.
And our job is, quite
simply, to make it easier
for you to do what you love.
So we focus on making you as
productive as possible with
the least amount of effort.
And so in everything we design,
we take all the feedback
that you're sharing with us
and build a cloud platform
that just works, whether
that's by natively embedding
key security or sustainability
features into the platform
itself, or by featuring
partner solutions right
within our own console.
We're really
focused on one goal,
giving you the best developer
experience of any cloud
provider.
APARNA SINHA: Google Cloud
has had tremendous traction
with digital native customers
since our very early days.
How have you seen
customer and partner
adoption evolve since then?
URS HOLZLE: Well, many
of our biggest customers
are cloud natives.
But we've seen
tremendous adoption
by a broad segment of
enterprise customers
in traditional
industries as well,
like entertainment or
financial services.
For example, Major
League Baseball,
which is North America's
oldest and most attended
professional sports league,
is using Google Cloud
to modernize fan
engagement and to increase
operational efficiency.
And Equifax, which
was founded in 1899
and is one of the
world's largest consumer
credit reporting agencies,
is transforming itself
from a credit bureau to a
next-generation data analytics
and technology company
built on Google Cloud.
APARNA SINHA: We've
seen a huge shift.
Essentially every company
is becoming a tech company
to increase their
competitiveness
and establish leadership
in their industries.
Developer talent
and cloud services
are at the heart of this shift.
Whether you call that digital
transformation or something
else, companies of
all sizes are finding
that Google Cloud is
optimized to help make
your data, your
applications, and your talent
more useful and relevant
to your business.
URS HOLZLE: Exactly.
And as Thomas
mentioned yesterday,
everyone needs to be
thinking through how they'll
fundamentally shift into
a technology company
to serve their customers in the
most meaningful ways 10 years
from now.
And you as developers are
key to making this happen.
So organizations ask
themselves, do we
have the most cutting-edge
technology to become
a leader in our industry?
And you, the developers, are
well equipped to answer this.
And we are super
focused on making you
and your company successful.
And there's two
areas we focus on
to support your growth--
first, of course,
making it easier for developers
to get their job done, second,
investing in the
developer community
so that everyone can learn
and grow from each other.
So let's talk about
how Google Cloud is
making it easier for developers
to get their job done.
From our transformational
infrastructure
stack to our deep innovations
in data, security, ML,
every feature we release starts
with simplifying the developer
experience.
Take our open cloud
experience, for example.
We recently expanded
our compute stack
to include Tau VMs that deliver
42% better price performance
over any other comparable
solution in the market
with no recompile.
And thanks to our zero-trust
approach to security,
Google Cloud was ranked
a leader in IaaS platform
native security by Forrester,
well ahead of the competition.
And of course,
we're focusing also
on managed services that make it
easy for you to deploy, scale,
and manage Kubernetes clusters
on the edge or in the cloud.
And Google Cloud has the
most complete and most secure
container experience
for developers.
In fact, the 2021 Gartner
Solution Scorecard
for Google Kubernetes
Engine gave GKE
an overall score of 92, again,
well ahead of the competition.
And of course, with
GKE and Anthos,
you can run these
containers anywhere--
on premise, other clouds,
on the edge, anywhere.
So it's fair to say that in
the years since Google invented
Kubernetes, containers
have really completely
revolutionized IT operations.
Now, recently, European
filmmakers from Honeypot.io
created a documentary on
the history of Kubernetes.
And it will be out
in January 2022.
And you are the
very first audience
to have a look at the
trailer right now.
So let's roll that.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Do I have to look
at you or the camera?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- 2013, it was clear
that cloud was a thing,
but most folks were focused
on infrastructure cloud.
- The dirty secret
for a long time
was people who were either
building their own data centers
or using colos.
There's a huge resource waste.
- And so at that
point, automation tools
are all the rave.
People are now trying to
abstract away the servers.
- Google was looking
for ways to apply
its internal infrastructure
expertise to the cloud.
- As we started looking at
technologies like Docker,
we were impressed
by the strength
of what they'd
accomplished in solving
a very specific problem.
- This is going to happen
with us or without us.
- Google had to make a bold
move in the cloud space to be
the long-term winner.
- Every big startup,
I felt like,
had a container
orchestration project.
And half of them were
announced at DockerCon 2014.
- Open source is most
successful when it's played
as a positive-sum game.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
APARNA SINHA: This is
such a great community.
URS HOLZLE: Yeah, absolutely.
I recognize a lot
of the faces, and I
can't wait to see the film.
Now let's get back to how
we're making it easier
for the developer, for
you, to build really
the leading technology
companies of tomorrow.
Now, Kubernetes deployments
can involve a fair bit
of manual configuration,
clusters, nodes, load
balancers, YAMLs, et cetera, but
not on Google Cloud, because we
offer you the most automated
and secure Kubernetes
experience available.
With GKE Autopilot, Google
provisions and manages
the cluster's entire
underlying infrastructure,
including control plane,
node pools, [INAUDIBLE]..
And that lets you focus on
the higher-level services
and applications
that you're building.
Nobody else offers
anything like this.
Because beyond
managing node upgrades,
GKE Autopilot also automatically
configure security features
like Shielded GKE nodes, secure
boot, and workload identity.
And it also implements
security best practices
by blocking less-safe features,
like external IPs or legacy
authorization.
So you don't get a
toy Kubernetes cluster
with GKE Autopilot.
You get a sophisticated
cluster that
uses the best practices
brought to you by the team that
brought to you
Kubernetes itself,
so you're always up to date.
And you get the same
results as the experts
without having to be an
expert, too, yourself.
APARNA SINHA: The
pandemic put developers
in the driver's seat, and
you all drove GKE usage
to all time highs.
At the same time, we
saw explosive growth
in the use of Google Cloud
serverless offerings,
especially Cloud Run
and Cloud Functions.
It's mainly
enterprise developers
who have driven this growth.
Cloud Run excels at
developer experience.
It's earned the highest
customer satisfaction rating
among developers as measured
by user research international.
Cloud Run combines the
best of both worlds,
bringing you serverless
and containers.
There's no cluster to
set up or configure,
so developers are able to
scale seamlessly and securely.
Under the hood, Cloud Run
scales container instances
in isolated sandboxes.
Any access outside a
sandbox is mediated
by network controls, or Identity
and Access Management, or both.
And it isn't just for new apps.
Cloud Run supports
traditional workloads,
like Java Spring
Boot and asp.net.
We also recently introduced
committed use discounts
to lower the cost at scale,
and we've introduced always
on CPU, which enables
asynchronous and background
processes to be
used on Cloud Run.
So you have all the
benefits of serverless
without the restrictions.
The theme here is easier, more
secure development, especially
with remote work.
URS HOLZLE: You're
absolutely right.
We've been focusing on remote
development for some time now,
but the pandemic has certainly
accelerated the shift.
Now, what would be more
essential to remote development
than to be able to use
the full power of GCP
right from your laptop
with zero local setup?
Cloud Shell Editor is a context
aware remote development
environment that lets you
develop and manage applications
securely from any browser.
It supports languages, like Go,
Java, node, Python, C sharp.
And it comes with an integrated
debugger source control API
Explorer.
And if you want to test
locally on your laptop,
it also comes with local
emulators for Kubernetes
and serverless APIs.
APARNA SINHA: Thanks,
Urs. Next, let
me introduce you to Abby Carey.
She is going to show us how
Google Cloud makes it easy
for you to securely build
modern applications, again,
right from your laptop.
Hi, Abby.
ABBY CAREY: Hi, Aparna.
We developers have
had a hard time
writing, extending, deploying,
and operating applications.
But it doesn't have
to be difficult.
Let's start with
Cloud Shell Editor.
It comes with current versions
of your favorite DevTools,
like Docker, Minikube,
Scaffold, and more.
There's nothing to download
or install locally.
Tutorials are built into
Cloud Shell Editor, which
makes it easy to come up
to speed on complex topics,
like GKE.
APARNA SINHA: So no more
switching between tabs, Docs,
your terminal, and your code.
This integrated
experience is highly
differentiated
from other clouds.
You can even offer
your own tutorials,
and that allows
your organization
to share best practices and
on board new hires faster.
ABBY CAREY: Another
popular feature
is Kubernetes YAML
authoring assistance.
Let's say, I want to add YAML
for a service to this project.
I compress Control
Space, and then find
the Kubernetes service snippet.
Now, I can tap through
and fill everything in.
I also get auto completes.
And if I happen to make
a formatting mistake,
I am notified that there's
an issue in real time.
APARNA SINHA: Now,
many of you prefer
to work locally in an IDE.
This same YAML
authoring assistance,
it's also available for VS code
and IntelliJ via the Cloud Code
plugin.
Cloud Code has built in
support for both Cloud Run
and Kubernetes.
ABBY CAREY: In fact, if you're
using Cloud Run or functions,
you don't need to know Docker.
You can build and deploy your
app with just one command,
because Cloud Code--
because Cloud Build is
integrated under the hood.
This is an application
with no Docker file.
With the new gcloud run deploy
command, all I have to do
is provide a name
for my service,
and then let it know where
my source code lives, which
is this current directory.
And we're deploying.
APARNA SINHA: So nice.
And thanks to this ease
of use, 98% of users
deploy an application to
Cloud Run on their first try
in less than five minutes.
ABBY CAREY: I just showed Source
Code deploys the Cloud Run,
but there are more ways Google
Cloud has made deployment
easier and more secure.
First, I can scan my
build container images
to check for vulnerabilities.
I've already run an on demand
scan on one of my images
using gcloud artifacts
Docker images scan.
Now, I can copy
the ID of my scan,
and then view my images
vulnerabilities with the list
vulnerabilities command.
And then, once that's
finished, a severity level
is assigned to
each vulnerability
to help you prioritize.
APARNA SINHA: That's
super important.
It's really helpful in
addressing security concerns
earlier in the software
development lifecycle.
But now, what if your build
pipeline is compromised?
ABBY CAREY: For
that, I can enable
Binary Authorization on my
deployed Cloud Run services.
This way, only trusted
container images
are deployed to production.
APARNA SINHA:
Binary Authorization
is truly unique in the industry.
It enables you to put proactive
security measures in place
to reduce software
supply chain attack
risk by blocking deployments
that violate policy.
And speaking of
deploying, we're making
it seamless for you
to do CI/CD securely.
You can take advantage
of serverless
build environments within your
own private network with Cloud
Build private pools.
ABBY CAREY: And
for advanced CD, we
have Google Cloud
Deploy, which allows
you to create custom delivery
pipelines for your specific use
case and needs.
APARNA SINHA: That is so cool.
Well, a real application
connects to many supporting
Cloud Services.
So, Abby, can you
show us an example
of how we make these
integrations easier?
ABBY CAREY: Sure, when
creating a Cloud Function,
it's easy to integrate
with Secret Manager.
First, create a secret
that stores your API
key, which I've already done.
Now, I can either
mount it, as a volume,
or expose it as an
environment variable.
I'll mount it, as a volume, and
then I'll name my mount path.
This will always point to the
latest version of my secret,
and now, I can securely
reference this API key
from my source code.
This abstraction enables
portability and a better
local development experience.
Cloud Run also integrates
with Secret Manager
to make it easier to
do the right thing
and not put sensitive
data in source.
APARNA SINHA: I
love that so much.
OK, so now, you've
written your app.
You've deployed
your app, and you've
connected your app to other
Google Cloud resources.
What's next?
ABBY CAREY: Operating
your app in production.
With Cloud Ops, you
get one integrated view
for your alerts, events,
metrics, and logs.
No more jumping
around multiple tools
as you try to understand
what went wrong.
APARNA SINHA: That
was so awesome, Abby.
Thank you for
sharing this with us.
ABBY CAREY: Thanks, Aparna.
APARNA SINHA: In each
of these instances,
we've done the
integration work for you.
Because the more work we
put into this, the less
work you have to do,
and this principle
applies to security as well.
We've put a lot of energy into
building security natively
into everything
we do, so that you
can innovate with assurance.
Both GKE and Cloud Run
benefit from the security
fixes we implement before
vulnerabilities are exposed.
Just think about the
famous vulnerability
uncovered in how Kubernetes
was handling proxy requests.
We found it.
We coordinated and
communicated the disclosure.
We fixed it for the entire
Kubernetes community,
and we patched all our
products before any customers
were impacted.
More recently,
cyber threats have
shifted the focus towards
the software supply chain.
URS HOLZLE: That's right.
Malicious actors are trying to
compromise the software supply
chain from bad code
submission to bypassing
the CI/CD pipeline altogether.
And to help solve
these problems,
we proposed an industry
standard called SLSA.
It's a security framework
that provides common criteria
for increasing
levels of software
security through automation and
through cryptographic signing
at each stage of the
software supply chain.
And that makes it possible,
but not necessarily easy.
So making it easy for
developers to ensure security
is super important.
And that's why we're focusing
on building this security
right into the
developer tool chain,
anticipating and preventing
issues ahead of time,
not when you're most at risk.
So, for example, Cloud
Build, our service
that lets you build,
test, and deploy
across multiple
environments, such as VMs,
serverless Kubernetes,
or Firebase, now
offers Salsa level one
compliance by default.
Because Cloud Build gives you
a verifiable build provenance.
So this provenance lets you
trace a binary to the source
code that it was built
from to prevent tampering
and to prove that
the code that you
think you're running actually
is the code you are running.
Cloud Build is the first
and only CI/CD service
to offer this capability,
but we go beyond that.
As you've seen, build
integrity automatically
generates digital
signatures, which
can then be validated
before deployment by Binary
Authorization.
It's another Google Cloud first.
So without you needing
to do anything,
we prevent anyone
in your organization
from deploying code that has not
been built by your legitimate
build system.
Now, ensuring security
post-deployment
is equally critical.
On GCP, you can enable
continuous scanning.
And you can use our service
mesh to embrace a zero trust
security model, and
automatically and declaratively
secure your services,
and the communication.
So you can manage
authentication, authorization,
and encryption between services
with little or no changes
to the applications themselves.
Let me say that again.
With little to no changes to
the applications themselves.
So that means that these
security improvements
help secure not just new code,
but also, existing binaries.
So you can use them
for any application
that you're migrating
to the Cloud.
Both Anthos Service Mesh,
and now, Cloud Build Hybrid
are available across
Google Cloud and your on
premise environment.
And they work with VPC Service
Controls and VPC peering
to automate the developer
security for your enterprise.
No other Cloud provider protects
your software supply chain
to this level,
because we started
working on software
supply chain security
long before it was
in the headlines.
So by choosing GCP, you
benefit from this leading edge
focus on security.
APARNA SINHA: Whether we're
building foundational Open
Source technologies,
like Kubernetes or Istio,
or turning them into
fully managed services,
like GKE and Anthos
Service Mesh,
our goal is always to reduce
complexity for our users.
By helping create these
industry standards,
we can provide safer
and simpler services
for you, the developer.
And that's exactly our approach
to securing the software supply
chain.
We've co-founded the Open
Source Security Foundation
with other technology leaders
to create security standards
for Open Source software.
And we're starting to
bring products to market,
like Open Source Insights,
which provides you
a complete transitive dependency
graph for many Open Source
packages.
Now, let's turn
back to Urs to hear
why Google Cloud
is best positioned
to support you in
becoming a technology
leader in your industry
using data as a core asset.
URS HOLZLE: Thanks.
Yes, so far, we've been talking
about developing and managing
code.
But data is at the heart
of many enterprises.
So we also have the
leading data Cloud products
in the industry designed
for optimal performance
and reliability for
applications of all sizes,
while scaling to
immense capacity.
Now, let's start with databases.
When it comes to databases,
every Cloud gives you choices.
They offer SQL databases, which
are great, but unfortunately,
don't scale.
And, of course,
no SQL databases,
which do scale, but
unfortunately, are not SQL.
Only Google Cloud gives you
a third choice with Spanner,
because Spanner is SQL.
And, in fact, it just
got a Postgres interface,
but it scales horizontally.
And it can literally handle a
billion requests per second.
Nobody else has a
scalable SQL system,
so it's no wonder we're
seeing huge adoption.
Now, on the data
warehouse side, we
have, of course, the
leading Cloud data warehouse
with BigQuery.
Hundreds of customers are using
BigQuery at petabyte scale
today, petabyte each, and you
can run, of course, BigQuery
on AWS or Azure.
On top of that,
Open Source systems
for data lake processing,
like Flank, Spark, and Beam,
run natively on Google Cloud
in a simpler and more cost
effective way than in
other environments.
In fact, you can
realize a 57% lower TCO
compared to on premise
data lakes for data science
projects.
Now, on top of that
savings, our data Cloud
also includes the
world's first and only
autoscaling and
serverless Spark service.
And finally, Google
has deep partnerships
with leading data driven
companies, including
Databricks, Confluent, MongoDB,
Redis Labs, and many others.
So together, we help customers
access an open platform
that powers analytics at
scale, yet, is easy to use.
APARNA SINHA: Our
partner community
is central to the health
of our Cloud business,
and we're especially excited
about the innovation coming
from our data
Cloud partnerships.
Together, we've optimized
our infrastructure
for performance and efficiency
to give our partners
that extra edge when
they run on Google Cloud.
One of our leading data
partners is MongoDB,
and we have their CEO Dev
Ittycheria here with us today.
Welcome, Dev.
DEV ITTYCHERIA: Hi, everyone.
Happy to be here.
APARNA SINHA: Dev,
one of the trends
we're seeing in our
enterprise customer base
is that they're now
competing for leadership
positions in their industry by
becoming technology companies.
How would you say Google Cloud
and MongoDB working together
can help these customers
achieve that transition?
DEV ITTYCHERIA: Well,
Aparna, the companies
who are in the leadership
positions in their industries
are those who have built their
competitive advantage using
software and data to
transform their business.
And the key word here is build.
You can't buy a
competitive advantage.
You have to build it.
This means you need to enable
your developers to innovate
as quickly as
possible, whether it's
building new software to
seize new opportunities
or to respond to new threats.
MongoDB and Google Cloud
deeply understand this.
Developers choose
MongoDB on Google Cloud,
because we give
them the tools they
need to be as
productive as possible,
including having our services
available in the Google Cloud
console for easy
discovery and deployment.
Today, MongoDB Atlas
runs in 24 Google regions
across the world with deep
technical integrations
with Google's
analytic and AI tools.
This enables our customers to
innovate quickly and emerge
as leaders in their industries.
As a result, we're
seeing explosive growth,
our customers embracing the
true value of our partnership.
APARNA SINHA: That's incredible.
So when you think about
the development teams
at these new customers,
what's the biggest challenge
that you're helping them solve?
DEV ITTYCHERIA: Yeah, when
you talk to developing teams,
you find that they
spend the most
amount of their time trying
to work with data as serving
relevant data at the right
time to the right audience
is critical to building
any application.
Unfortunately,
relational databases
are not designed for the way
developers think or code.
Nor are they designed for scale,
fault tolerance, or resilience.
Consequently,
development teams find
it hard to move fast using
relational databases.
MongoDB is designed to
address this problem.
We make it very easy for
developers to work with data.
And we're able to address the
most demanding requirements
for performance, scale,
and fault tolerance.
The partnership with
MongoDB and Google Cloud
enables developers
around the world
to easily build modern software
applications to address
their needs of
today and tomorrow.
APARNA SINHA: That's terrific.
Thank you so much for
being here with us today.
DEV ITTYCHERIA: Thank
you for having me.
URS HOLZLE: Yes, thanks,
Dave, for joining us.
Now, there's lots
of ways developers
can improve their productivity,
automate tasks that
are repetitive, master
the command line,
use the best tools that
make your life easier,
or reuse other people's
code just to name a few.
And another great way to
accelerate your productivity
is with building
blocks, or templates,
or fully managed services in
areas, like machine learning.
Because on Google
Cloud, you don't
have to be an expert to
build smart applications.
With new services, like Vertex
AI, you can build, deploy,
and scale more effective
AI models quickly.
So that lets you
deliver the insights
to your organization that
will help them create more
personalized
customer experiences,
run more efficient processes,
and take that leadership
position in your industry.
APARNA SINHA: So with that,
let's go to our next live demo.
Joining me today
is Anu Srivastava.
She's going to show us how
these breakthroughs in AI
are advancing Cloud adoption
and redefining the world
of document processing.
Hi, Anu.
ANU SRIVASTAVA: Hey, Aparna.
We all know how to
work with data when
it's in a structured format,
like in a database, some JSON,
CSV files, or just
variables in my code, right?
But, what about
unstructured data?
Many of the world's business
processes start, include,
or end with a document.
But these documents can
be difficult to process.
Think about all the ways you
could enhance your application
if you could just
unlock that data.
This is where Google Cloud
Document AI comes in.
Doc AI is a platform that
has solutions and tooling
for automating your workflows
backed by machine learning.
We've bundled together some
of Google's flagship AI
technology, such as Computer
Vision, OCR, Natural Language
Understanding, and even
Google's expertise and building
knowledge graphs.
All to provide you with a
simple, yet, powerful way
to build applications
that better
understand unstructured data.
Let's go see a demo
of Doc AI in action.
So here, we have a receipt.
I was buying some
office supplies
since we are, unfortunately,
not back in the office yet.
What I'm going to do is I'm
going to actually upload this
into the Doc AI platform.
So in our Cloud console, we
have the Doc AI platform,
where we have built
in preview mechanisms.
So you can test
out your documents.
So this is going to
an endpoint, which
has a specialized model we
have specifically trained
on a variety of expenses.
Google maintains and
improves the models for you.
APARNA SINHA: Wait a minute I
hope this is not with my data.
ANU SRIVASTAVA: Absolutely not.
We never use your data
to train our models.
Your data is only used
to serve your request,
so let's take a look
at the data extracted.
APARNA SINHA: I've
seen this before.
Next, you're going to
tell me that you're
going to automate my expenses.
ANU SRIVASTAVA: I knew
you would say that.
This is the canonical
demo use case, right?
But, have you ever
seen it, like this?
Take a look at this field
that I'm highlighting,
the supplier address.
This address isn't present
anywhere in the document.
APARNA SINHA: Wow, where
did that come from?
ANU SRIVASTAVA: This is only
possible with Google's Document
AI.
The secret sauce here is
that the knowledge graph
is able to not only give
you back the original text
from document.
But it's going to
enrich your response
akin to what you'd see in a
search, but as part of your API
response.
APARNA SINHA: Wow,
that's really great.
ANU SRIVASTAVA: And
it's not just this.
We have several
specialized models
for many more document types
of much higher complexity.
Let's take a look
at this payslip.
So I ran this earlier, and we're
looking at the preview output
again.
You can see that
we have some keys.
We have some fields.
You can see enrichment on the
employer name and the address.
Once your data is in
a schematized format,
meaning that we know for every
document of a certain doc type,
there are common important
pieces of information.
So what we did is we
predefined a set of keys.
So what we do is, with
your extracted data,
we merge your data to
these pre-defined keys.
So it's much easier to
work with than raw OCR.
So once it's in a
schematized format,
it's easier to pass on
to a downstream service.
Or maybe you're using
something for analytics,
like BigQuery or Looker.
APARNA SINHA: That
makes sense, but what
about ensuring accuracy?
And, also, do you have
multi-language support?
ANU SRIVASTAVA: We know that
with important documents,
such as these, you can't
afford any missteps when
it comes to accuracy.
So that's why Doc AI
provides a human in the loop
configuration to trigger
on confidence scores,
so either for specific keys or
on the entire document itself.
And as for a
translation, we support
over 100 languages, such as
Spanish, Japanese, Arabic.
No other solution on the market
supports such a wide array
of languages.
APARNA SINHA: Human in
the loop, translation,
and knowledge graph
capabilities that
can be applied to a wide
variety of documents.
This seems super useful.
Of course, the next
big question is, can it
be applied to big,
bulky, complex documents,
like business contracts?
ANU SRIVASTAVA:
Let's take a look.
So here, I read a contract
earlier this morning.
You can see that there
are typical things
you'd find in any contract.
There are some document
names, the parties involved,
some dates.
And like with every
easy to read contract--
I'm being sarcastic here.
--there is an expiration term.
So this expiration date
actually isn't present
anywhere in the document,
and it's actually not
easy to figure out.
It's not in an easily
parsable format.
Shocker.
Google's contract processor is
able to figure out this date
value by understanding
signals found
across the entire document.
APARNA SINHA: Wow.
Well, Anu, before
you go, can you
tell our awesome
developers how they
can get started with Doc AI?
ANU SRIVASTAVA: Absolutely,
so I know we covered
a lot at just breakneck speed.
So check out the
breakout sessions
on Doc AI to dive deeper.
You can also check
out the documentation
for code labs and quick starts.
We have client libraries and
all of your favorite languages,
such as Python, node.js.
My personal favorite is
Java, but it's an API.
So you can really use this with
whatever platform or framework
you're already using.
We are thrilled and look forward
to see how you use Google Doc
AI to power your applications.
APARNA SINHA: That was amazing.
Can I have a high five?
ANU SRIVASTAVA: Yeah.
APARNA SINHA: Thank you, Anu.
I loved every part of it.
ANU SRIVASTAVA: Thank
you for having me.
URS HOLZLE: Another area that
Google has invested in deeply
and that's becoming more
important to more companies
is sustainability.
Many Cloud providers have
a vision for a sustainable
future, and many aim to match
their electricity consumption
with 100% renewable
energy by 2025 or 2030.
We accomplished 100%
renewable energy in 2017,
so we're the only hyperscale
Cloud to do this today.
And all of that
with data centers
that are twice as efficient
as the average data center.
APARNA SINHA: This
past week, Sundar
talked about Google's goal to
enable over a billion users
to live and work more
sustainably by next year.
To reach goals, like
this, and those outlined
in climate pledges made by
more organizations every day,
we rely on developers, like
you, to do something about it.
But we also know
that it's difficult.
URS HOLZLE: That's right.
One of the biggest challenges
that companies face
is that they lack
the tools to account
for environmental costs, and
to help developers address this
for their organizations, we
built sustainability tools
directly into Google Cloud.
With Google Cloud
Carbon Footprint,
you have access to the
energy related emissions data
that you need for external
carbon disclosures in just one
click.
Now, you won't need
this calculator
if you just want to report
the net carbon footprint
of your workload on GCP.
Because on GCP,
it's always zero.
We also have our
Region Picker, where
you can choose the data
center region with the lowest
gross carbon cost right now.
Of course, again,
your net impact
is zero, no matter
what region you pick.
But this tool lets you
help go one step further
to become carbon free,
not just carbon neutral.
Now, that's actually a
tool that I can't wait
to deprecate in 2030 or so.
Because Google Cloud has
committed to be 100% carbon
free by 2030 every
hour of every day.
Now, we also realize
there's still
a lot to learn when it comes
to building sustainably,
and to help, we just
released a master class
called Sustainability
IT Decoded with some
of the world's top experts.
So check it out for
guidance on how we can all
build more sustainably.
Now, while we're proud
to run the cleanest Cloud
in the industry, were even
more inspired by the work
that our customers are
doing with Google Cloud
to solve climate
change challenges that
are unique to their business.
And today, we
bring you a preview
of Google Earth Engine and its
integration with Google Cloud.
With over 700 data sets
and 50 petabytes of data
today, Earth Engine gives
scientists and developers
access to the world's largest
catalog of satellite imagery
and to tools for driving
sustainable impact.
APARNA SINHA: So let's look
at this in a bit more detail
with an example of how Google
Earth Engine and Google
Cloud enable customers
to assess risks
arising from climate change.
But instead of me
telling you about it,
we've invited Joel
Conkling to show you.
JOEL CONKLING: Thanks, Aparna.
The world is
constantly changing,
and that creates
opportunities and risks.
Helping uncover critical
insights about the changing
world is why we're integrating
Earth Engine into Google Cloud,
and that integration is
now in Private Preview.
Today, I'll demo a workflow
that combines Vertex AI, Earth
Engine, BigQuery, and
Google Maps platform
to show how Google Cloud makes
it incredibly easy for you
to innovate, and deliver
insights, and do it quickly.
So here's a scenario.
You work at an
insurance company,
and you need to analyze
your company's exposure
to flood risk.
You think new buildings
may be a strong contributor
to that risk, and you want
to test your hypothesis.
To do that, we first need to
understand where the built
environment is expanding.
In other words, we just need
to categorize the surface
of the entire planet.
That could be
hard, but Vertex AI
offers the tooling to develop
a best in class ML model.
And Earth Engine provides
constantly updated data.
Let's fast forward a bit.
We finished training our
model, and now, Earth Engine
is sending satellite
imagery to be categorized.
So your understanding
of the world
can update in near real time.
Here's the Earth Engine script.
I'm showing the
results of that model.
This area in red is
where the model estimates
the locations of buildings.
That's your current
built environment.
To find the change over time, we
need a few more lines of code.
These lines of code give us
a built environment in 2016,
and here, we calculate
the difference
between 2016 and today.
When there's a change, it
shows up in purple on the map.
This is where there
are new buildings.
So next, we're going to export,
sample, and export the data.
So we can do additional
analysis in BigQuery.
Over in the BigQuery
console, this script
clusters those data points
here and then outputs
polygons that show the areas
with the biggest changes
in the built environment.
So at this point, you
have a few options.
You could combine this
data with flood locations
you identify around the world,
also, with Earth Engine.
Maybe you want to enhance
your model with weather
data and physical terrain data.
That's available on
Earth Engine too.
You could also include data
on your company's insurance
portfolio to gain additional
insight into critical risks.
We'll wrap up this demo
by visualizing our results
in a new feature available
on Google Maps platform,
the Open Source Data
Viz Library Deck
GL with a BigQuery
connector provided by CARTO.
So we now have a clear picture
of where the built environment
is changing, and where to
focus next for our work
on flood risks.
In summary, no
wrangling data, no need
to manage infrastructure,
just actionable insights
incredibly quickly.
We can't wait to see what
you'll do with Earth Engine's
new integration
with Google Cloud,
and with that, I'll
pass it back to Aparna.
APARNA SINHA: Thank you, Joel.
It's incredible to see
how our customers can
use our sustainable technologies
to address climate change now.
I'm really inspired
by all the things
we've talked about today.
And thinking about
how you're going
to lead your companies into the
future, that's super exciting.
No pressure, but it's
really up to you.
We've invested millions
in the developer community
over the last five
years, and we'll continue
to invest in the coming years.
And, Urs, as proof
of that, I understand
you have some additional
news to share today.
URS HOLZLE: Absolutely.
I'm really excited
to announce today
our new developer community
program called Google Cloud
Innovators.
I want to welcome and introduce
our first group of leaders
who are driving meaningful
impact in the industry
and their communities.
So take a look.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[TYPING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
APARNA SINHA: This
is so exciting.
URS HOLZLE: Yeah,
through this program,
we'll give developers access
to early technology previews
and Google engineers.
We'll recognize the expertise
of our community influencers
by promoting their
contributions,
and we will work
closely with them
to solve the toughest problems.
So we're excited
to come together
with this group of innovators.
Join us at
cloud.google.com/innovators.
APARNA SINHA: So cool.
I've been waiting
for all this time.
Community is extremely
important for companies
to create that much needed human
connection with developers,
and we hope that this
gives you a window
into the motivation
that you all give
Google to build Cloud products
and services that developers
love.
URS HOLZLE: And we look
forward to partnering with you
to become the greatest tech
companies in your industries.
APARNA SINHA:
Remember to join us
next at the live developer Q&A
session, and also, tomorrow
at Community Day.
Enjoy the rest of the show.
URS HOLZLE: Thanks, everyone.
[MUSIC PLAYING]